tuna are predators but is one of the
world's most popular seafoods they're
also prey tuna is a staple on menus
everywhere from pizza to sushi tuna
sometimes up to five metres long used to
be found in abundance in all the world's
oceans schools of tuna can travel at
speeds of up to 80 kilometres per hour
but they're still helpless against
industrial fishing vessels five of eight
species of tuna are now endangered if
tuna become extinct the economy of
entire countries will suffer acutely the
population of the solomon islands in the
pacific for example depends on tuna
fishing for their livelihoods 60 tons of
tuna are processed in the coastal town
of Nauru every day about 2,000 Islanders
earn their living with tuna including
hearty ma tomorrow he's in charge of
quality control at soil tuna this canary
it's really important to the people here
to the lives with their families
to the surrounding communities as well
we're worried if the sooner stuff is
done yeah because the job here defend
very much the fish that we have in our
waters the Solomon Islands commercial
fishing fleets net around 55,000 tons of
tuna per year
captain Pattaya deliver otter his crew
were all local but they use fishing
methods their ancestors wouldn't
recognize it's quite easier now when
this there's a spot of fish 100 meters
away the sana can tell you the density
of the fish how many tons there is how
deep it is and how far it is once the
school of fish has been located it's
doomed the crew get the nets in position
the trawler starts to circle
and moments later the tuna are netted
it's so easy that it makes the captain
uncomfortable as a Pacific island of
myself I would ask one question will the
next generation enjoy this industry as
we do now
it's so very easy to catch fish
that's the worrying but more bugs and
more fish harvested from the sea the
Solomon Islands belong to the Pacific
Islands Forum fisheries agency
established to protect fish stocks other
members include Australia as well as
many small island developing States
countries that don't belong to the
Alliance are not allowed to cast their
nets within a 200 kilometer radius of
the FFA zone the FFA monitors an area
spanning 40 million square kilometers
interesting track it's not licensed so
it should not be doing those tracks if
this is definitely looked innocent
passage much like airplanes the vessels
send signals making it possible for the
FFA to identify illegal trawlers but
this alone doesn't solve the problem of
overfishing revised fishing quotas for
locals as well as greater expertise are
also crucial the FFA is therefore set up
a research program to study tuna in
depth Direction finding transmitters
show what sort of distances they cover
in their lifetimes what they feed on and
how fast they grow yes one wasn't
doesn't live in and receive it only now
ocean ologist Andrew Hudson says the
data will help protect tuna stocks the
good news is the Pacific Island
countries have taken concrete steps
toward improving their understanding of
the fisheries improving and putting in
place management regimes and monitoring
and compliance regimes that if they
carry them forward in full which I think
they're capable of doing could could
lead to true sustainability for those
fisheries going forward
in order to secure the livelihoods of
their own descendants the Pacific states
need to ready their oceans for future
challenges